on me dit bonsoir vous avez 20 ans vous
avez déjà fait vingt films x
professionnels 22 22
c'est encore mieux et vous avez aussi un
dock de philo vous l'avez eue à l'âge de
18 ans c'est pour ça qu'on vous appelle
19 mais voilà que les chiffres ouais et
vous avez fait 1 68%
et c'est pour ça qu'on vous appelle
l'intello du x c'est je n'ai pas
forcément voulu mais on m'appelle
l'intello du x est un fait bah oui vous
êtes la seule à mon avis qu'il ya un bug
de phil hogan oui mais bon c'est vrai
que je trouve ça un peu péjoratif
intellos du x parce que ça voudrait dire
que sous prétexte que j'ai un bac de
philo je suis plus intelligent que les
autres alors que alors que vous laissiez
le prof en fait
bien alors vous dites je suis une sex
workers c'est assez bien alors bout du
temps plus que 22 films en deux ans
c'est rien du tout parce que si j'avais
choisi n'importe quoi j'aurais pu en
faire une centaine un film se tourne
dans cinq jours et cinq nuits maximum
maximum maximum vous avez finalement été
très raisonnable très bien choisi vos
rôles et vous êtes devenu en très peu de
temps une star du x est vraiment bien
que maintenant vous êtes maintenant je
veux maintenant avant de dire en chef
chez garda ce que je dis 202 commencé à
18 ans j'ai attendu d'être majeur alors
il ya trois promo pour vous donc vous
allez faire trois fois ça vous allez
voir une fois
deux fois
laurent votre mauvaise esprit vous
perdra bon original c'est plus la peine
d'aller réserver ses complets jusqu'au
mois de juin 2002 donc laissé tomber
perdez pas votre temps à téléphoner
aller faire la queue bien alors d'abord
vous êtes dans mortel transfert vous
vous êtes battus par qui
on sait
pardon mystère mystère il ya une mode sn
en ce moment là je visais dans un
magazine cette semaine que vous êtes
abonné à des trucs sur ce marché dans
max est pas un magazine tellement
underground un cédant max il ya un club
à new york où on peut aller se faire
fouetter à l'heure du déjeuner puis
c'est vrai il ya dans l'article
de surf ou été bon alors votre deuxième
promo ses orgies en noir qui était un
film écrit réalisé par vous et produit
par marc dorcel on va en parler aussi
répété l'ex
y'a pas après
et la deuxième chose c'est donc la
sortie au printemps aux éditions trames
d'un extrait qui s'appelle les femmes et
là pendant la fête voilà c'est ça c'est
titre très provisoire avoir bu
attention au vide vous êtes né en 1981
c'est bon la date oui
bien en fait votre nom est tiré d'un
personnage de bd c'est ça oui ovidie la
sanguinaire et une rate une petite
trappe en super d2 petit luxe se dilate
ont-ils eu campus comme par hasard bien
dans l'enfance vous avez fait beaucoup
de danse classique
j'ai fait de la danse classique du
modern jazz de la danse africaine et de
la danse orientale vous dites je compare
souvent le porno à la danse évidemment
le porno c'est la danse déstructurée
mais de la danse quand même il ya la
même recherche de performance corporelle
c'est de l'expression corporelle moi
j'appelle ça de la performance
artistique j'ai fait des performances
artistiques à côté c'est vrai que je le
vis à peu près pareil psychologiquement
vous avez été obligé de renoncer la
danse oui j'ai un problème douce eau
piégée à l'antigène méchant qui fait que
je ne peux plus dense et bien alors à 13
ans vous décidez de plus manger de
viande oui vous devenez végétalienne ce
qui n'est pas végétarienne dans moi j'ai
eu un fils mais manger
non alors végétalienne c'est pire que
végétarien pas ce que vous mangez au
pire ailleurs c'est mieux c'est mieux si
vous voulez pas de viande tas de
poissons pas donné pas d'oeuf jusque
reste grâce tout le reste tout ce qui
n'est pas du mal les céréales légumes et
fruits dérivés
chez crauland il faut des sites romains
dans le sport mais beaucoup
aidé à cacher derrière les pattes ça
toujours été pas de sens
aucune drogue n'ont même pas de
cigarettes même pas d'alcool rien non
vous êtes street west
reich oui et comment on se sent si total
contrôle sur tout mon corps et je me
sens vraiment bien comme ça c'est vrai
qu'on a des boules de métal qui pousse
jeudi sait pas c'est que par ce traité
c'est un truc existe aux états unis et
les gens qui sont street et aux états
unis vous n'êtes pas parler de ça
pendant le tournage non mais on sait pas
vu un seul était de dos et
aux états unis elle a quand même pas de
relations sexuelles c'est dans ce truc
c'est vrai mais là bon d'après moi c'est
ça vire un peu aux religieux ya des gens
qui sont 80 de ses actes au bout d'un
moment
ouais mais bon ça va moi je fais que ce
qui me met pas nous y est ce qui me rend
bien donc les relations sexuelles ne
sont pas prohibés heureusement dans
votre métier mais dites moi alors
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui vous reste
non mais sérieusement si vous fumez pas
vous buvez pas vous sexe
bonne réponse de jean hugues anglade
alors la saison à vous quittez vos
parents
vous avez à tour avec le petit ami de
l'époque
bac un punk à rester un pain cuit bac
littéraire latin avec mention
et vous découvrez à ce moment là la
pornographie imboulou et des cassettes
un plusieurs films x par semaine
pourquoi ce vous ennuyer avec votre
petit copain le pain mais je trouve non
je sais pas un jour j'allais jouer mes
cassettes vidéo au vidéo club juste en
bas de chez moi et je me suis dit tiens
si j'allais faire un petit tour dans le
petit recoin tout cacher et j'y suis
allé j'ai vu des jolie jaquette avec des
jolies filles me suis dit tiens donc
j'ai regardé et là j'ai vu des superbes
américaine et là je me suis dit c'est
extraordinaire je veux faire ça quand je
serai plus grande ah ouais c'était une
vocation quoi ils sont venus pour les
tournages sont maintenant et c'est un
vrai travail mais n'empêche pas qu'ils
ont ça vachement bien beaucoup mieux que
d'autres
imaginez être à 4 heures du matin avec
25 cm à 5 cm en bas ventre
avec un rhume et caetera et que vous
arrivez à faire croire à la caméra que
vous avez énormément de plaisir moi
j'estime que c'est la comédie quand vous
commencez à militer dans les groupes
d'extrême gauche à cette époque-là
groupe libertaire
mais même pas la fédération anarchiste
parce que vous trouvez qu'ils sont trop
se dém trop sociaux-démocrates les
anarchistes alors qu'est-ce que ça
devait être vous étiez dans quoi à
l'époque j'étais au réseau no pasaran le
sous commandant marcos et tout ça quoi
oui enfin disons qu'on soutenait le
peuple du chiapas soutenait beaucoup de
gens comme ça mais je les ai quittés
parce que je trouvais que
leur quotidien ne correspondait pas du
tout à leur discours vous êtes rendu
compte en fait que même les anarchistes
étaient choqués par vous et par votre
façon d'être et votre façon de vous
habiller quoi donc j'étais pas si nrj ce
que ça a finalement vous êtes rendu
compte
c'est vrai que à l'époque moi j'aimais
bien m'habiller je m'aime bien maquillée
j'aimais bien portée des jolies
sous-vêtements mai camarade porté des
tris
des sweat shirt à capuche certaines se
raser le crâne et moi ce n'était pas du
tout montré vraiment pas et puis bon je
trouve ça un peu facile de dire qu'on
est anti sexistes et qu'on met des
taloches à sanaa n'a quant à elle a pas
fait la bouffe ou quand elle regarde
quelqu'un d'autre et vous êtes féministe
procès que sur ça veut dire quoi ça moi
je suis pour le fait que les femmes
s'assume en tant que femme et pas en
tant que images ou imitation de l'homme
je suis pour que les femmes
s'épanouissent
sexuellement donc je pense que quelqu'un
qui n'est pas évanouie sexuellement ne
peut pas se sentir bien et donc le 17
décembre 2012 est allé à l'assemblée
nationale voir le conseil national des
verts c'est à dire que vous êtes une
militante politique en fait oui je ne
fais pas du tout parti des verts mais
j'ai été invité par les verts pour
intervenir sur la prostitution
et moi j'ai je suis intervenu sur la
marchandisation du corps parce qu'il y
avait un texte contre la prostitution
qui s'appelait mon corps n'est pas une
marchandise ou je sais pas quoi et moi j
ai expliqué en quoi je trouvais que
l'argumentation de la marchandisation du
corps était une argumentation très
phallocrate finale oui oui parce que
vous dites y'a pas de raison que la
marchandisation du corps s'applique
qu'aux activités sexuelles en fait on
peut le mec qui bosse en usine c'est la
marchandisation du corps aussi d'une
zaouïa de ça et puis ce que j'ai
expliqué c'est que d'après moi le fait
de dire une femme vend son corps quand
elle a une activité sexuelle
ça revient un petit peu à cette idée de
du don de soi et du pénétrant qui domine
ne pénétrait etc et je trouve ça un peu
limite quand on se dit féministe et bien
c'est
vrai
ils ont une
autre idée en fait c'est de convaincre
les femmes que la pornographie peut être
saine et ludique
et c'est vrai qu'en ce moment elles ne
sont pas toutes persuadé non mais je
pense aussi que c'est parce qu'il ya une
grande partie de la pornographie qui
effraie les femmes tout ça mais il ya
une autre partie de la pornographie qui
est très machiste on voit des filles qui
font la tronche qui seront démontés ça
donne pas envie point même moi j'ai
envie d'apporter une pornographie plus
saines ou la nana elle regarde le film
et qu'elle se sente déculpabiliser vous
en pensez quoi vous non moi je suis tout
à fait d'accord et j'ai déjà commencé à
céder t&d au maintenant mais je veux
dire je veux dire que je regarde ça
m'arrive assez régulièrement regarder
des films pornographiques avec ma copine
d'assurer les choses se passent très
bien bien sûr et voilà alors vous êtes
dans le film de bennett donc mortel
transfert on la dit quand vous avez
rencontré pennec si vous a demandé jeudi
pourquoi tu fais pas du vrai cinéma ça
vous a énervé oui ça m'a vexé parce que
j'estime faire du vrai cinéma ouais je
fais du cinéma pornographique c'est on
peut dire c'est cinéma du pauvre mais
c'est du vrai cinéma c'est un jean c'est
un genre qui vous plaît oui énormément
bien alors orgie ont noirci du bo de
films que vous avez écrit réalisé celui
là produit par marc dorcel pour les 20
ans de sa société de production alors
c'est quoi l'histoire
c'est une histoire comme on en voit dans
neuf films z sur dix c'est à dire c'est
un jeune couple bourré qui arrive dans
un cimetière qui meurt
parce qu'ils se prennent la foudre et
ils se font attraper par des zombies les
ombres et les amène devant la reine des
morts et appelé qui est moi et après il
l'air dans le cimetière
en essayant de trouver la sortie
désespérément et la reine dément elle
est punie de la sacrilège je veux gagner
tous ces jeux
[Musique]
j en or 2010
alors donc effectivement wuyts est un
mélange de film x et de série z vous
dites j'aime tout ce qui est un peu
mauvais cinéma terre les perches qui
apparaissent dans le champ d'un manteau
c'est normal
l'annuaire
on peut pas faire un film parfait en
cinq jours 5 nuits c'est impossible on
voulait faire un cinéma porno égalitaire
vous dites oui tu as envie de montrer un
cinéma porno ou pour les femmes pas
forcément puisque la terre pour les
hommes et les femmes des hommes et les
femmes prennent du plaisir ensemble ou
séparément procès qu'on peut faire du
porno hétérosexuels non sexiste bien sûr
le fait de faire l'amour devant une
caméra c'est parce existence moi
c'est difficile de faire un film qui
plaisent aux femmes sans que ce soit un
film lesbien non
je me suis posé la question plein de
fois est ce qu'on peut faire un film
hétérosexuels non sexiste mais je pense
que oui c'est possible bon là je suis en
train de travailler sur mon deuxième
film et j'ai beaucoup plus penser mes
scènes de sexe et je pense que j'ai
montré des scènes de sexe très
différentes et très intense
hétérosexuels vous dites c'est pas
génétique que les femmes puissent pas
être excité par la pornographie c'est
seulement d'ordre culturel
il ya combien de films x qui vous ont
excité vous qui m'ont excité vraiment je
dirais qu'il y en a eu trois ou quatre
mâts même sur plusieurs centaines titre
parce que si ça vous excite et vous je
crois que ça va se vendre
c'était des films américains
s'appellent touchez pas aux grosses des
briseurs de cues chanter moi c'est
laurent
vous sur le plan personnel vous préférez
les femmes oui
c'est pourquoi comment et pourquoi pas
ce que vous avez commencé comme ça où
j'ai commencé comme ça ma première
relation sexuelle avec une femme je
préfère les femmes savez vous êtes
mariée et je suis mariée
avec un homme
non mais on décide pas de qui on tombe
amoureux tombée amoureuse de lui et
c'est un accident
je suis mariée avec lui depuis bientôt
deux ans et se passe bien dans la masse
bien
mais c'est vrai que à la base j'ai quand
même une préférence pour les biens vous
aimez pas alors il ya des filles qui
aiment les femmes qui aiment les femmes
qui ressemblent à des hommes vous
séparez vous aimez les familles les
belles gonzesses quoi c'est des gros
seins et tout c'est ça c'est vraiment
les femmes comme un homme aime les
femmes 60 ans
alors vous êtes très exigeante sur vos
tournages vous exigez un préservatif
vous dit en parlant des actrices de x et
altaï des people se font limay pendant
des heures pour un tarif ridicule s'en
fiche de paie avec des horaires de
l'enfer et sans protection
le fond oui pas tout heureusement mais
il y en a qui qui subissent away
et moi non john ça vous coûte des
tournages et des gens qui vous considère
à cause de ça bien sûr est ce que on est
très peu en europe à ne tourner qu'avec
préservatif on est tout petit tout petit
et en plus à avoir plein de conditions
sur les pratiques vous refusez on peut
le dire pour organiser la malle avec
sommes pas bons mais j'accepte avec
femmes seules avec ce soir avec
accessoires est ce que quand on fait des
faits de la scion sur un plateau on peut
en même temps accumulé des points
retraite
mais ça a l'air ce type de question et
c'est une vraie question c'est surtout
la grand-place grand que c'est une
question d'actualité
est ce qu'une couverture sociale c'est
beau la sueur je suis intermittente du
spectacle
y en a qui hésitent à se lancer dans
cette corporation se disant oui mais
j'assure pas l'avenir il ya des points
retraite ouais oui donc vous refusez
l'anal vous refusez lesjak faciale c'est
pourquoi c'est une question de
protection quand on demande à tourner
avec préservatif et qu'on se prend du
sperme dans l'oeil ça sert à rien vous y
avez vous savez qui est dans les films
pendant que ça se fait ça parce que
j'aurai qu'on repense à mon avis c'est
bien pour ça que même moi en tant que
réalisatrice par exemple bien sûr ça
s'appelle orgie en noir
alors vous savez on me dit qu'on ne
bouge pas mal jean galle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien leur en faire une interview
bendaoud dans votre métier vous avez des
hauts des bas en vérité à lui à bndes à
ce que vous préférez en vous
encourage ce que vous haïssez chez vous
mon orgueil ce que vous préférez dans le
cinéma
et kung fu comédie à ce que vous
détestez
les films violents et la mort
représentait dans le film où vous jouez
vous préférez
un film qui s'appelle max où je joue une
petite charrette et où j'en vois
férocement boulet le match au
joli vous détestez je le sais moi
x y z ah bon la fête à jj non je n'aime
pas la fête à jj parce que c'est mon
premier film que c'était pas moi c'était
pas encore on me dit oui sinon le film
qui m'a vraiment le plus perturbé os x y
z pourquoi
je regarde pas forcément un bon souvenir
et j'ai trop donné de ma personne ouais
trop consciencieuse des fruits
les plus grands moments de votre vie
mon mariage
le pire
si on fait répond ah bon c'est pas
maintenant moi non non non bon la mort
d'un proche ouais ce qui vous plaît le
plus dans la vie
docu
désagréable
ce que vous détestez
encore une fois la violence j'ai une
peur panique de la violence votre plus
gros coup de fric
ces derniers temps il ya eu plusieurs
coups de frais que ces derniers beaucoup
de fric beaucoup non voilà ce que je
fais pas un métier on gagne
d'un coup votre plus grosse perte de
fric
bon voyage singh avait payé non j'ai eu
beaucoup d aide de la part de ma famille
mais c'est vrai que on ya laissé des
plumes mais je fais comment ce mariage
là parce que c'est le plus beau moment
de votre vie c'est ce qui nous a coûté
le plus cher donc on aimerait quand même
savoir c'était un grand mariage
végétalien ailleurs c'est pas la bouffe
qui vous a coûté cher aimer les légumes
et les pattes non c'était un très bon
repas
avec tous mes amis et tous les amis de
mon marié toute la famille c'était bien
c'était cool si vous fait le plus rire
mon avis les petites bêtes allez hop
ce qui me fait plus rire c'est que
puisse rire ouais je reviendrai sur le
cinéma tout ce qui est filmé ça décoiffe
ou comédie ouais ça aurait vraiment pu
aller et je vous fais le moins à ryad en
mode et
la violence non mais c'est vrai j'ai
revenir là-dessus mais je suis
extrêmement parano et j'ai extrêmement
peur des violences elle tapote ses yeux
votre plus belle histoire d'amour passée
avec votre mari alors oui
incontestablement est la plus minable
par les grecs avec qui vous êtes allé à
tournon
ouais je dirais que j'ai un peu stagné
pendant deux ans avec amex oui j'ai un
peu stagné c'était quelqu'un de très
très bien mais
ça m'a pas fait beaucoup avancer parce
que vous avez plus sexy en vo
tatouage
à la la ça fait deux bons de tadla et ce
soir c'est l'état tout événement est-ce
que vous avez deux mois sexy
j'aime pas mon ventre est ce qu'il à
votre ventre c'est pas beau ah bon on
verra
ce que vous préférez dans le sexe
et femmes avec des gros seins c est que
non vraiment vraiment étonnant si vous
détestez dans le sexe est macho
on me dit maman tel transfert
georgie en noir
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu de
bleu